-Our next guest is a comedian
you know from his work
in the "Jackass" franchise.
His book,
"A Hard Kick in the Nuts:
What I've Learned from a
Lifetime of Terrible Decisions,"
is out now. Please welcome
to the show Steve-O, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Steve-O, I'm very happy
to have you here.
And I don't think it will come
to anyone's surprise here
that this was not
a staged photo.
You really did allow yourself
to be kicked in the nuts
for this picture.
-I insisted on it.
-You insisted on it.
-I did.
-It looks -- Do you have to get
the right kind of person
to be the kicker?
Because I imagine
that's a big part of it.
[ Laughter ]
-You want someone who's
going to be stern but fair.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Now, you've also given out
some kicks over the years.
-I have. I have.
-Yeah.
-I'm absolutely confident
that I have been both asked
to kick people in the nuts
and have kicked people
in the nuts
more than anybody
who has ever lived.
-Yeah.
-So if someone sees you out and
about, that might be the thing
they want even more
than a selfie?
-Oh. Oh. It's on a daily basis.
-Really?
-And they'll be passionate
about it.
Like, "Dude, is there any way
I can get you
to kick me in the nuts?"
And my position on it
used to be,
"Who am I to dash
a man's dreams?"
-Sure. Very kind of you.
You're very giving.
-But I've since matured,
and as such, I've retired
from nut kicking.
-That's very both understandable
and a little --
I don't know. A little sad.
You know?
-It is. It is.
But that's just not
the kind of energy
I'm trying to put out there
anymore.
-Yes.
Well, I like that there's --
This book is sort of a mix
of the old and the new.
-Yeah.
-I think maybe an example
of the old is,
to promote the book,
you went driving on a truck
in sort of I guess, like,
a porch swing? Is that...?
-It was exactly a porch swing.
-Uh-huh.
We built a porch swing
onto a cube truck.
And that's me
going over 50 miles an hour
down a freeway in Los Angeles.
-Gotcha.
Now, I think people assume that
you are a man without fear,
but that would actually
not be true.
And I would imagine one thing
is that you have to face
a lot of your fears when
you write a book like this.
-Yeah.
-And this book actually starts
by saying, "I started
this book as a joke,"
but then it gets very honest
about the issues
you've faced over your life,
including issues like addiction.
Did that -- Was that the plan
when you started?
Or did you sort of find that
in the writing?
-I put out a memoir in 2011.
It was a "New York Times"
Best Seller.
It has a five-star rating
on Amazon.
Like, by every measure,
it was my proudest work.
And over the course
of 10 years,
since that book came out,
I thought,
"Man, my life has been, like,
even crazier since then.
I got another book in me."
So I reached out
to my literary agent, who said,
"Sadly, "Memoir Part 2'
is not a thing.
So you need to come up
with some kind of angle on it."
And what I landed on
was a book of wisdom
gleaned from a lifetime
of terrible decisions
to serve as a vehicle
for telling all the crazy
stories from the last 10 years.
-Yeah.
So it's basically a memoir
wrapped up in a self-help book.
-Correct.
-But it does actually
have elements of both.
-Right. It's about 90%
"Wow, is this guy nuts?"
and 10% "He might have learned
something from that."
-Another fear you faced is,
you know, sort of later in life,
you started doing standup,
which I think might be scarier
to some people
than any of the stunts
you've done in the films.
Was it scary for you
the first time you did it?
How did it come about?
-Well, the first time I did it
was now 16 years ago.
2006, I got invited
to a comedy club.
Somebody asked me to do a stunt
on stage at the comedy club.
I showed up totally wasted,
no plan,
walked in and thought,
"Wow, the craziest stunt
I could possibly do
would be to try standup."
And I was scared.
I came up with one joke that
I'm not allowed to say on TV.
-Okay.
-It got a laugh.
And I was addicted
to the idea of it.
Ended up really, really
going for it.
And, yes, in the beginning,
it was more scary than anything.
-One of the things --
As a huge fan of the franchise
and of all of you guys --
And I know you guys
have coped with success,
which is often really tricky
for a group of friends.
-Yeah.
-Had to cope with tragedy,
obviously, which is
even harder to deal with.
But it's been really special
to watch you guys
continue to make content.
-Right.
-Do you feel that
when you're doing it?
Like, "This is insane
that 20 years into it,
we're still all together?"
-Everything about it
is absolutely shocking
and unbelievable.
-Yeah.
-I mean, if --
Like, the fact that it even
started is pretty shocking,
let alone that it's endured
for decades
and the fact
that we're all still friends.
You know?
We're basically a band.
"Jackass" is like a rock band
that just doesn't have any
talent for music or anything.
-I've heard you call it
a "wholesome" show,
which I don't think
that would be what
a lot of people would say.
Make a case real quick as to why
"Jackass" is wholesome.
-I absolutely maintain
that it's wholesome
because it's devoid
of anything mean-spirited.
There's nothing hateful
about it.
Sure, we give ourselves
and each other a very hard time,
but we're all such attention
whores, we're begging for it.
-Yeah.
-So...
It's completely permissible
that we are so hard on ourselves
and each other.
And as far as anybody else goes,
there's just nothing
mean-spirited about it.
The spirit of "Jackass"
is genuinely wholesome.
We're just here
to brighten up people's day.
-Well, I want to thank you
because mine
has been brightened up many
times over the last two decades.
-Well, thank you.
-Thank you for being here.
Congrats on the book.
Come back soon, man.
Really appreciate it.
Steve-O, everybody.
"A Hard Kick in the Nuts"
is out now.
We'll be right back with
Dick Ebersol, everyone.